as we look back at once a year 2022
speed I'm sure there's one thing a lot
of you regular viewers have in mind it's
all about the action and the way videos
on Battle anime have done exceedingly
well on this channel prove that honestly
the same things on my mind too 2022 has
given us a lot of good action shows but
amongst the tens and hundreds of fights
there are some that stand out much more
than others so today that's what our
list is about it's time for me to start
the road to the end of the year by
looking at what I think are the top 10
fights of 2022
foreign
psycho has always set a gold standard of
Excellence in animation to the point
where its other perks somehow got pushed
to the Wayside I'm not saying this is
completely true but at times it seems
like that the writing and character
development in mob psycho just doesn't
get talked about enough in favor of the
animation mob psycho truly is an amazing
anime and it's not so often that a show
can quickly shift your mood from being
all eyes on screen from a fight to
ripping your heart out with dramatic
moments but they did that this season
featuring a side character I'm pretty
sure not a lot of us cared about that
much beforehand but let's not take
anything away from the fight now shall
we it's nothing short of amazing to see
dimple go all out in this way and it's a
slugfest that we typically don't
associate with mob psycho a side
character fight that stole the show is
the best way to describe this
[Music]
foreign
we proceed with Attack on Titan's fight
involving everyone against the jagerists
did you really think that once the
primary Titans have been dealt with the
best of aot had passed well a few people
seem to think that way given the
reception to this final Arc and I am
inclined to agree but at the same time
the final Arc also gave us some cool
fights like this one first the Titans
are still here and while they've been
taken down a peg the addition of the
whole human to human combat aspect more
than made up for it for all the
complaints at the final season of aot
got you can tell they didn't skimp a
single bit on the animation and the
quality control for this episode The
Fighting is just so fast and intense as
something that brings back memories of
the old days back when the whole world
was still feeling the shock and awe of
this anime smashing debut I'm not sure
if this can hold a candle to something
like season 3's climax but it sure is
worth a mention due to how awesome it is
with the big Titans out the way I want
to blame you if you think that the aot
hype would have subsided a bit but this
whole sequence should prove otherwise
the Titans may not have retained the
Threat Level they had in the series
first half but they sure pulled their
weight in this battle
get along
for our next entry we look at Team Ruby
versus nightmare Blake
ice queen gym has been a mixed bag for a
lot of people including me personally I
like the direction they did with the
series but that's also because I wasn't
such a huge fan of the source material
and therefore it didn't have much of a
passion for it as the hardcore fans do
however what I can tell is that in terms
of battles ice queen dim has been
hitting the right notes and my favorite
amongst those fights is the one against
nightmare Blake there's something I
really love about these Ensemble fights
mainly due to how teamwork shines
through and you can clearly see how each
member of the team has a role to play
amongst the many action sequences in the
series this has become my favorite by
far in addition to a decent fight
choreography you have the emotional
Stakes at play and the Very catchy music
oh and you see likes comments and all
sorts of Engagement help the channel
grow and make this video do well so if
you're liking the video so far I want to
see more of it be sure to drop a like
and leave a subscription to the channel
thanks and I hate to hold you up any
longer so let's proceed looking back at
it princess connect did make one great
impression on me so let's feature it
with this fight right here
[Applause]
[Music]
it's rare to expect a gacha game
adaptation to have this much care and
budget given to it but as we've seen as
the season went on cygames really threw
in a lot of ships at the anime
adaptation of Princess connect the
second season has vastly improved on the
first one adding the more intriguing
plot and more action to the mix the
final battle against Kaiser Insight may
seem quite simple but it's a fight that
you'll enjoy a lot more once you get the
context right it's the culmination of
pekarin's storyline that was briefly
teased in season one and fully explored
in season two seeing her stand up and
take responsibility as the true princess
and take it to one of the most despised
villains in its season was a thing of
beauty both figuratively and literally
the anime team used much of season 2 to
show off the animation Chomps and this
fight is no exception it's a pleasing
climax to a show that has surpassed all
expectations coming in even if you've
watched season one season two is such a
huge change of pace in a good way it's
hard not to get goosebumps on scenes
like this
foreign
my hero Academia is still going strong
after all this time and if you're
craving for more intense action like
you've seen in the series climactic
fights then I present to you the much
awaited shigaraki fight shigaraki has
sure built a reputation for himself
through the years it's not like he was
just some random side villain when he
was introduced but it really Rose
through the ranks these past Seasons
culminating in a triumphant run last
season now with all the hype he's built
he finds himself taking on Endeavor and
the heroes watching him take on Endeavor
seem like a Titanic Showdown that's just
destined to happen and it didn't
disappoint it's just one of the fights
where you can really feel the intensity
emanating from the two fighters and
having Deku and friends in such close
calls adds so much to the tension if
you're still not convinced that
shigaraki has what it takes to take the
mantle of the ultimate villain then this
fight will surely change your mind
all right
how could we not feature chainsaw man
especially with the Banger of the battle
they gave us with denji versus leech
demo there
isn't that a rather minor fight in the
manga well yeah it is but with the way
the anime team produced it anime onlys
wouldn't know they truly poured their
hearts out in presenting this fight the
best way they could and the results are
glorious sure the insane action is
something that we've all come to expect
as this is four episodes into the show
that doesn't make it any less good
though and this one's pretty much on par
with everything we've seen so far
personally I praised the fight more for
the voice acting and how it really
conveyed the character's state of mind
you can truly feel denji's Madness as
the fight goes on that's a far more
effective way of getting us to know his
character even more especially in an
aspect that some people feel was a bit
overlooked in the anime this battle gets
a mentioned here because of how the
anime took this relatively minor fight
from the manga and elevated it to new
heights it's one of the best things that
I credit for the success of shows like
Demon Slayer and bleach and looks like
chainsaw man is quickly joining good
company
foreign
[Applause]
summertime render makes a list with the
fight versus the Shadows
if there's a show in recent memory
that's so beautifully portrays
determination and resilience from a
ragtag group of people who put
everything on the line then it's
summertime render I don't know if a lot
of you share my opinion but I think this
is one of the best shows to utilize the
time loop system and the way it
transitioned from some murder mystery to
Pure Thriller action is nothing short of
beautiful with this fight marking a huge
Turning Point an entire episode of
summertime render never felt as short as
this one with the human team combining
their skills to outplay shida and Jaime
an inching ever close to victory in
addition to the quota for Action being
filled it's still filled with the
various mental gymnastics and strategy
that have come to love the show for
shinpei and group were never going to
beat the Shadows but with enough
strategy and learning thanks to his
Loops they were able to finally take one
from the seemingly Unstoppable enemies
summertime render is a strong Contender
for anime of the Year for me no joke
perhaps this fight would encourage you
to try the show out
oh
my god
with bleach fever being alive once again
I feel like part of me has been
transported back to the 2000s but does
the original bleach series have a fight
as blazingly as intense as this one for
so long fans have always wondered what
yamamoto's Bankai really is sure he's
technically the strongest amongst the
captains but his powers are a bit too
simple considering all the broken stuff
we have in Bleach right a bad guy that
just makes more Flames I mean that
sounds lame that is until we finally get
to see an action though turns out it's
not just fire but fire utilized in
various ways all modes being
mind-blowing in their own right okay so
technically this isn't a fight more of a
big time Flex moment if you ask me so
there's something I can consider when
the next volume of that comes out they
literally made an episode of yuhan
getting completely annihilated then the
plot twist drops
foreign
piece is back at it with the fight
against kaido making the list
when has a one-piece fight gotten you
this excited before seriously I haven't
felt this excited for a confrontation
before and I've spent a good part of the
past decade watching some one piece make
no mistake in the whole gallery of One
Piece villains there's no one that got
me as excited about the prospect of a
climactic clash as kaido did and the
fight shattered my expectations too I've
read the Manga of this part but seeing
it animated and with sound just made
everything so much better the whole
thing is just insane and it's like the
one piece team putting their 120 for
this fight we've seen some well animated
battles before but this one just hits so
different the fight is filled with a lot
of epic moments that you just gotta
watch to believe it's also amazing to
see kaido's endurance in full display
here I mean the guy spent so much time
fighting back to back to back to Great
payoff to one of the most built up
villains in the series
foreign
[Music]
versus [ __ ] and gutaro
half a season is a fight Preposterous
but that's just what team 10gen versus
[ __ ] and gutaro is a long fight drawn
to Encompass half a season and every bit
and segment just as exciting as the one
that came before it looking back at it
having half the season be an extended
fight might sound insane but it sure
didn't feel like it when I was watching
it especially if you compare it to the
kaido fight which is probably a
year-long fight but while the battle's
ongoing and people come in and out we
get some side points running in the
background while the action rages on up
on the surface classic Demon Slayer
goodness all throughout with the
well-paced fights the still astounding
animation of moves and the excellent
presentation make it each moment as
tense and gripping as it should be you
just can't get off your seat while
eagerly awaiting the result of each
action and that's what makes battles
Shonen like this so fun to watch I also
would like to point out how [ __ ] and
youth Auto make such an amazing
combination in terms of strength and
Powers I spent time wondering how the
heroes would defeat these two they're
not something super numbering Invincible
villain of Doom but the fight against
him is a puzzle that makes the whole
battle so engaging
so with that we wrap up the list I
wonder how you'd rank these fights
against each other make sure to share
your top three or five in the comment
section down below your help and support
will also go a long way in helping us
make even better videos so the team
would deeply appreciate the likes or
subscriptions that you can give us well
that's it for this list I hope you
enjoyed it thank you for watching and
I'll see you next time